I think one of the great thing
about startups is that it
puts a great big hurdle in
front of future employees.
It tells them look,
if you want to work here,
you're going to take a huge salary cut.
Yes, you get equity, but you're going to
sacrifice a lot with the potential for
amazing rewards but
it's just the potential.
That high bar usually attracts,
potentially,
those employees you want to to hire.
You want to to make sure you don't
try to compete with salaries,
often you can't.
You want to make sure that you
compete with your company's vision.
You want to compete with the culture,
you want to compete with what it is that
the company does that no other company
in the world can offer because you're
doing this unique thing that will have
a significant impact on people's lives.
Selling the vision is your
number one tool to recruit and
the good news is it's aligned with
finding those amazing employees that can
really change your
company in the future.